so what i want to do is i want to know
what values the time and alpha
are going to get me there okay does that
make sense
so what i want is this now this is
question one well and truly
okay i want simultaneously so for some
single value of
t okay i want x to be two thousand
and i want y to be zero okay and now you
can see why i developed these time
equations
right because there they are
there's my x value right and
there's my y value okay so
suggestions come on some of you can
already see what to do
where might i go first
what shall i start with because i am
going to solve simultaneously
where should i go where should i go
well you have these two choices right
which do you think is a better option to
start with
probably the x equation far simpler
right so if i write this
x equals 200 t cos alpha
ah but i i have an x that i'm actually
after a specific x namely
2000 yep
okay now look at this for a second what
does this mean
what's this all about constant
constant
that's variable i'm trying to find what
that is what about cos alpha
also constant so the only thing that
makes sense to rearrange this thing into
is to say make t the subject right does
that make sense
so t is equal to cancel
cancel tan on cos alpha by the looks of
it
okay what is this time
this is when i've traveled from zero and
i've gotten to two thousand
so far so good but at that time that
specific time i also want y to be zero
okay so i'll say also
right there's my y equation right i want
that
to be equal to zero there you go so now
i'm actually climbing with this
particular point
and i can sub in my values of t you get
this
okay it looks a bit messy but that's
okay stay with it what can i do with it
well let's see that's a hundred isn't it
so minus five times a hundred
that's minus five hundred that cos
squared alpha
is on the denominator so i can call him
sex squared and i think you can see why
that might be a good idea to
go right good direction to go in what's
going to happen here
that's 2010
okay this is good this is good because
now we have an equation alpha which is
the guy i'm trying to find
okay what shall i do to this before i
actually
whip out quadratic and all that kind of
change i should change
well there's two things i can do to make
it simpler i can change this guy with an
identity
and i can get rid of all of this fluff
right there's a bit of a mess okay so
i'll do the numbers first
this
yeah is that okay now we change this sec
squared is equal to
tan squared plus one or one plus ten
squared okay so that's going to if i
rearrange this into a nice
quadratic order it's going to look like
that
okay gross okay that's all right
we can deal with it okay can you
factorize it
not nicely okay so i'm going to solve
for tan alpha
okay follow with me see if i get this
right minus b
4 plus or minus the square root of
16 minus
4ac which is just 4 yep
all on 2. so far so good
get going 4 plus or minus the square
root of 12
on 2. now
this looks really awful it looks truly
awful
before we calculate it let's just note
something
how many solutions are there here there
are two
why are there two
let's get our calculators and see
exactly what it means now you wouldn't
expect to get something nice out of this
would you
well let's do one and then we'll do the
other let's do the smaller one
four minus three twelve on two tan
inverse so
four minus
root
and what do you get
i'm looking for my first angle tan
inverse of four minus through 12 and two
if i've got it already
surely you guys can catch up with me
let's do it in degrees just for the heck
of it someone got an angle for me
15 degrees exactly 15 degrees
that's interesting what's the other
angle
all you need to do is change the minus
to a plus you get
75.
okay that's interesting what does this
look like
my beautiful diagram okay that looks
like it's about 75
gear or tank where's 15 on this diagram
something like that isn't it is that
right
so in other words there's a low angle
and there's a high angle and they both
work you can put them all in
and they'll both pass through two
thousand zero sure enough
that's interesting you should note that
very frequently you will get this double
solution business happening
okay now that's not the only thing
15 and 75 15 and 75
suspicious they're complementary
they're complementary why is that
if i drew a better diagram like this
and maybe you should do the same i've
got
two solutions
wow that was lucky okay now where's my
15 degrees it's here
right my other angle because it's the
complement
is 15 degrees this way
that's suspicious right
i wonder how you could determine whether
that was a coincidence or not
i digress there's my answer there's
question one
where do i aim and the answer is here or
here
fine okay now i've been talking a long
time i want you to see if you can finish
these two questions and then we'll come
back together because we've got two
places to aim
you're going to get two answers for each
of these parts how long is it flying for
you ought to be able to anticipate an
answer for me
and what's the impact speed and angle
for each call them case one and case two
and we'll come back together in six or
seven minutes
i'm sorry i'm not even i'm not even
integrating guys come on
classic four unit student like i don't
know
must be my part
sorry